so Dr Doom fights Kane the Conqueror and
Mephisto in the story and it's amazing
okay so check this out so this initially
picks up with something called the
antleon collider which is basically a
black hole that's being created on the
dark side of the moon it's more of a
controlled black hole it's basically a
minor Singularity but the reason why
this is done is because the world or at
least the scientific community on Earth
in the Marvel Universe wants to start
shifting more towards like nuclear power
different things like that but with all
the different forms of energy that are
used the big question that people find
themselves asking is what do we do with
all this waste right this energy waste
that we end up creating is it one of
these things where we're going to just
kind of keep on doing what we're doing
which is driving to the side of a hill
dumping our trash in the ground and then
covering it up or are we going to come
up with something that's a little more
elegant and more of a fitting of our
technological advancement and so that's
the idea behind this black hole is to
literally create a place whereby trash
can be dumped essentially for Infinity
right because black holes will break
everything down on the atomic level and
it may end up filling up up but I mean
it's it would take an astronomically
long amount of time in order for that to
happen the kicker to all this is that
while these interviews are being done
with members of the the antleon collider
Community they're also talking to Dr
Doom and they asked him the question
like what's your stance on this of
course Doctor Doom being Dr Doom is like
it's gonna fail right this whole thing's
being done by Reed Richards as
intelligent as he is the biggest problem
Reed Richards has is that he's sloppy
and because he's sloppy this is going to
end up failing disastrously now the
crazy thing about this is that you do
have this guy named Steve who's one of
the guys conducting the interview right
one of these reporters and he literally
says many believe that you're just upset
because you were left out on the project
and it has to be a failure because you
weren't involved now here's the thing
right anybody who knows anything about
Doctor Doom in Marvel Comics knows that
there are some things you just don't say
right like pick your battles wisely this
is one of those because when the
interview ends Doctor Doom just kind of
leaves in a huff and then tell tells one
of his guys bring the reporter Steve to
me bring that guy to me right like I
want my hands on that guy he's been
mouthing off and we need to help Steve
understand his place in the bigger
picture and so one of the things that
kind of goes on here and it's cool is
that while that's taking place you end
up having Doctor Doom in his study and
while he's there he's suddenly met by
the arrival of King the Conqueror now
when it comes to King and Dr Doom this
is one of those things where it's kind
of you stay away I stay away right in
the sense that because these two guys
are kind of distant relations to a
degree Kang doesn't really do a whole
lot in terms of intentionally going
after Victor Von Doom the reason for
that is that in Marvel Comics it's never
been fully established if Kane the
Conqueror is the descendant of Reed
Richards or the descendant of Victor Von
Doom but the risk here and even King
himself doesn't fully know if he were to
attack Doctor Doom anywhere to kill him
he could actually prevent his own
existence from happening and so he
doesn't really go directly against Dr
Doom and usually pick a fight although
the two have fought in the past and the
fights between Dr Doom and Kang are
usually amazing like they're some of the
coolest fights you're ever gonna see
mostly because it's Kane to conquer
brandishing all his technology and time
travel escapades and as Dr Doom was just
like the best one-liners ever in the
history of comic books it's Phenom no no
I will say apocalypse has better
one-liners but Doctor Doom has great
one-liners he's got great lines but it's
just one of those things but it's also
because of the fact that Doctor Doom is
so astronomically intelligent and
because he's so capable and because his
lust for power in a lot of ways mirrors
that of Kang there is a kind of respect
that is grown between the two also
because of the fact they've helped each
other at different points in time and so
Kang being here is one of those things
where it's a little mysterious we don't
really know why he's here in the first
place the nature of the conversation is
really more just kind of banter back and
forth between the two and that's
basically it and then Kang ultimately
just sort of teleports away but what
Doctor Doom ends up doing is as he
prepares for bed then he actually ends
up having this vision of of a woman that
we haven't discovered yet and she and Dr
Doom have a family right like they have
a whole full-on family and so Dr Doom
really kind of going back to his
quarters right after this sort of
hallucination which really even takes
him by surprise he ends up opening the
door only to find that he's on the moon
where the entire antleon project has
gone awry according to his prediction
it's manifested a full-scale black hole
and is sucking everything in around it
now here's the thing to understand if a
black hole opened on the moon if we
would die so fast we wouldn't even be
able to understand what had happened
right like literally it would just
probably be a flash of light and like
that's it that's all we would see but
the thing about this is that once Dr
Doom of course the next morning he's
basically told hey we have Steve that uh
he ends up going to find where Steve is
basically just kind of strung up
and he's like make sure he's fed today
tomorrow we might not feed him but today
make sure he's fed and so as Dr Doom is
kind of meditating and focusing on this
Vision that he received suddenly the
nuclear arms of vladviria fire off right
they literally just start going off like
all these nuclear weapons of vladveria
shoot off they head toward the ante Leon
uh Antion collider and basically destroy
the whole thing and because they um
because they originated from latviria
and because Dr Doom had been like yeah
man uh this the whole this whole thing's
gonna fail the immediate suspect for all
of this is Dr Doom and these guys come
swooping in right just I mean it's it's
shoot out of the okay Corral right guns
blazing the first one to show up here is
Union Jack he doesn't really matter all
that much but he is cool right he's one
of these characters where he never
really gets a whole lot of appearances
in Marvel Comics but he is cool and it
is interesting to see him from time to
time but the funny thing about this is
that while this attack's going on
suddenly Victor Von Doom is shot by
Agent Zero now Agent Zero is a lot more
capable Maverick was one of the original
inductees into the Weapon X Program
alongside Wolverine so while he's not
necessarily on the same level as
Wolverine regarding like adamantium
bonding and all that kind of stuff he is
probably one of the single greatest
assassins and mercenaries in the
entirety of the Marvel Universe it's
crazy how good he is and he even goes as
far as to say interpol's reward right
the international police the reward just
shot up for Victor Von Doom like
literally everybody's got it out for
this guy everybody's coming for this guy
and so where Dr Doom is able to
initially get the upper hand on both
Union Jack as well as as well as
Maverick he had instructed his staff
immediately issue a surrender right
immediately tell them we're surrendering
here because the worst thing we can do
is to actually face off against these
forces because what it does is it
implies guilt right like it wouldn't it
would indicate like yes we launched the
attack and I'll be damned if any is
going to come to Liberia and give me
you're never going to take me alive
right I mean it's it's that kind of
thing right and so ultimately he ends up
basically just surrendering to various
forces that show up here now once he's
taken he's actually brought in by a
combination of different things the
first two are silver Sable and Amy Chen
now these two are particularly important
but only in certain circles in Marvel
Comics so silver Sable runs a group
called The Wild pack which is one part
information brokering and one part
mercenary work so they are guys that
basically travel the world they pick up
people who are supposed to be picked up
by various governmental agencies or
corporations or what have you but
because silver Sable is networked with
so many different organizations and
groups out there she's basically a
person tied into a ton of information so
even if she's not necessarily coming
after you if somebody else is coming
after you they can actually hit up
silver Sable and if they're able to
offer the right price she'll give them
the information that they need the other
person that's brought here is Dr Stephen
Strange now the reason why Steven
strange is here is one because this
story takes place before he died and two
because as most people who are familiar
with Dr Doom and Marvel Comics know Dr
Doom and Doctor Strange have a very
strong history together the most notable
instance of the two of them working
together was when they traveled to
basically the realm of Mephisto they
traveled to hell and the story
triumphant torment in order to free Dr
Doom's mother from from mephista right a
free her soul so it could go to heaven
which they successfully did and in fact
that's something that I want you to keep
in the back of your mind because we'll
talk about that again in this story but
Dr Doom's various mystical abilities are
enough that they can match the powers of
Doctor Doom so if you want to try some
crazy you know Jedi mind trick mysticism
stuff Doctor Doom would be there to
basically bring it to an end but as we
know Doctor Doom has no real intention
of doing that now the irony behind all
this and this is the important thing to
understand based on the visions that Dr
Doom has been getting which he doesn't
really know the origin of of it and we
don't really even know the origin of it
at the moment is that these Visions
indicate somewhere along the line Dr
Doom does something which ushers in an
era of peace all across the world and
literally brings a kind of Utopia that
had never been seen before and so that's
why Dr Doom 1 allows himself to
surrender because he's kind of curious
about where these Visions are leading
but two Kane the Conqueror suddenly
appears inside this ship where Dr Doom's
at and it's one of those things where
literally Kings like I've seen your
future right years from now you're the
magnanimous leader of an eternally
peaceful Earth and it would be the most
preferable Earth for me to conquer and
so that's kind of the on running theme
like King the Conqueror will appear more
over the course of the story and really
if anything he kind of shows up I mean
Dr Doom does fight him a couple times
but he shows up more often than not in
order to help Doom because he's like the
things that you're gonna do are
basically going to make the earth a
Utopia but it's also going to make the
Earth weaker and it makes it easier for
me to conquer so like here's some stuff
to help you because in helping you I'm
helping myself right like that's really
what he does for a good chunk of the
story and it's hilarious the times that
he shows up it's funny but one of the
things that Doom says is okay if this
future you see is true and it matches
the visions that I've been having then
free me right like if you want to be
able to conquer the Earth in the future
because of what I'll end up doing then
free me and get me out of here and so
one of the things that they do is they
sabotage the the engines of the vessel
and then they basically Escape now you
guys are probably asking yourself why
don't they just teleport out of it the
reality is when you're dealing with king
marvel plays it fast and loose right if
Kang basically destroyed or or sabotaged
the engines it's because in looking over
all the different timelines it's the
only one where they successfully Escape
that's kind of the undercurrent that
Marvel uses right like King does
everything he does for a particular
reason but the reality is that once this
is done basically Kane teleports away
and Doctor Doom casts a mysticism in
order to save himself following that he
literally goes underground he Dawns a
kind of mask and hides himself and he
takes off to the city of New York now
when he gets there he basically ends up
encountering what are these sort of
visions of Morgan lafay now these
Visions come in the form of her
appearing on in like Times Square on TV
screens different things like that only
Doctor Doom can see her this is one of
those elements of Marvel Comics that's
really cool Morgan lafay has been around
for an exceedingly long time and in fact
she's been around about the same time as
Merlin in Marvel Comics and the thing
about this is she actually originates
from Atlantis or at least the Atlantean
territories before the gray cataclysm
during the second host when the
celestial showed up and then attacked
the deviants that is to say she's been
around for thousands of years and she's
incredibly powerful she's not the most
powerful person ever but it's kind of a
loose knit family between like her and
Dr Doom and Doctor Strange and like the
Scarlet Witch and brother Voodoo people
like that just these people that
practice like magic and mysticism which
is really weird when you think about it
because like there was a time when
Morgan lafaye and Doctor Doom banged so
that's kind of cool but the thing about
this is that while all that's going on
what you end up having is Reed Richards
of the Fantastic Four while it's off
panel he comes to the realization that
if Doctor Doom has actually escaped and
Doctor Doom's out there on the lamb then
what they need is someone who's every
bit as intelligent as Doctor Doom
meaning this person is one it like kind
of shares the number one spot for the
smartest person in the Marvel Universe
but is also immensely powerful powerful
enough that they can stand toe-to-toe
with Dr Doom and so what you end up
having is Herbie the robot who's kind of
like the robotic assistant of the
Fantastic Four basically traveling to
Cornell and meeting with Adam Brashear
and bringing Adam Brashear in as a
person that can actually capture Dr Doom
now a lot of people are going to ask the
question how in the world is it that
like blue Marvel is on the same level as
Doctor Doom is this just something
you're making it up Rob I'm not making
this up at all and the reason why I say
that is because there's a point when
blue Marvel is meeting with uh with
Herbie and you know at that point you
know blue Marvel's like okay so Reed
Richards is finally taking me seriously
and Herbie's like well you are the top
available right like you were using you
were the next best choice
which is kind of a crappy way to put it
but then Herbie also goes on to say you
match Dr Doom in intellect and strength
especially since he's without his powers
now the way that Herbie's drawing this
information is based on the information
that Reed Richards has in his database
what that means is that in Marvel Comics
what Christopher Cantwell is
establishing here that Reed Richards is
one well aware of who Adam Brashear is
which is something that we already knew
and then two looking at Adam Brashear
the blue Marvel top to bottom from his
intelligence to his strength to his
powers and so on Reed is basically
established that blue Marvel is as
intelligent and capable as Doctor Doom
what this means is that blue Marvel
shares the number one spot as the
smartest person in the world with Reed
Richards Doctor Doom and Valeria
Richards right it's a really cool moment
this is one of those things that you're
probably going to see people referencing
when other folks ask the question where
does Blue Marble reside in terms of
intelligent strength so on and so forth
and so following this what you end up
doing is picking back up with doom while
he's traveling with Morgan lafay and
they travel to meet a guy called the
witness now this is the one and only
appearance of the witness at least in
this form that I'm aware of in Marvel
Comics but the idea behind this guy is
he can basically look into the eyes of
another person and then see exactly what
their future is and what the witness
says is that Dr Doom is going to die and
it's the saddest day on Earth it's
absolutely beautiful but we don't really
find out exactly how this death happens
but what it does seem to do is kind of
fall in line with the visions that Dr
Doom's been having where he becomes this
person that literally saves the world
that it would be a tragic and sad day
because the world would have lost
somebody's significant to them the
kicker is that before any of this goes
down and any other questions can be
asked Dr Doom is killed on the spot and
he's actually assassinated and the
person who takes him out is none other
than task master Tony Masters I told you
this story gets amazing now again in
this moment what ends up happening is
because Dr Doom is by all standards of
measurement dead he wakes up in hell he
wakes up in the realm of Mephisto and
traveling there he basically Dawns this
kind of Hell armor which I gotta tell
you guys is probably the second most
badass doctor Dooms ever looked the only
thing better than this was when he was
God King Doom so he basically had his
normal outfit but it was all white which
was dope and I'm surprised no one's
cosplayed as God King Doom at any Comic
Cons it kind of astounds me but this
looks dope oh my God like it looks so
beast but what ended up happening is
Doctor Doom comes face to face with
Mephisto now the thing about this is
Doctor Doom tells him right off the bat
I'm not supposed to be here and the
response of Mephisto is that's what they
all say but I'm glad to have your your
soul now and forever and Doctor Doom
immediately attacks Mephisto now here's
the thing to understand about Mephisto
right this guy is a misnomer when it
comes to how powerful the Fisto is with
Mephisto himself he is at the peak of
his power when he's in his own realm but
he's not indestructible and he's not
Unstoppable but the thing about this is
that Dr Doom is immensely powerful the
reality here is Dr Doom's not powerful
enough to overcome me Fisto to beat him
in his own realm like this and so what
kind of goes on here is a bit of
bouncing back and forth where Mephisto
starts playing games with Dr Doom now
one of the other things that I want to
establish here is really kind of more of
a background of what's taking place is
that you do have the kingdom of latviria
where Dr Doom normally resides what you
have next to it is a place called
simcaria and socari has kind of been a
war-torn place for quite some time only
recently has it actually established any
measure of an organized government and
so what's going on here is that Sim
cardia is actually organizing battle
formations and they're in the process of
trying to conquer Liberia while Dr Doom
is not there so that's an important plot
point to keep in mind again we're not
going to be talking a lot about that but
we will talk about at the end because it
does become incredibly important at the
end of this but the thing about this
kind of focusing on the Here and Now
what Mephisto does is he tells Dr Doom
if you can convince Valeria that you
deserve to live then you can return to
your life now here's the thing Valeria
there's two different ones there's
Valeria Richards who's the daughter of
Reed Richards and then there's a
different Valeria so no we're not
talking about you know Valeria Richards
right this 11 year old kid that Dr Doom
was in love with that's weird right
that's weird and creepy and really
really gross Valeria is a character
who's exceedingly old school in Marvel
Comics and in fact she goes all the way
back to Marvel Superheroes number 20 in
1969 Valeria was a person who lived in
the same camp that Dr Doom did when he
was a little kid they were basically you
know they kind of fell in love as
teenagers as much as anybody could but
as Dr Doom became consumed by Vengeance
and power Valeria basically left him
behind right she just didn't want to be
a part of that life and as a result of
that she eventually fled Doctor Doom
caught up to her and basically convinced
her that he was going to leave all that
Madness behind and all he wanted was her
love and a life and so she ultimately
bought into it what was really going on
and probably one of the most just
amazing stories that Mark raid ever
wrote In The Fantastic Four back in
volume three back in 2003 the idea here
is that what Dr Doom had done is he had
actually tricked Valeria and he
effectively sold her soul behind her
back so that he could attain mystical
armor right enhance his powers and so
when that happened her soul was sent to
the realm of Mephisto it was a pretty
shady thing to do and that's why
Mephisto makes this claim if you can
convince the only woman in the world who
ever loved you that you betrayed her
that you deserve life then I will give
it to you and that's the crazy thing is
Victor Von Doom tries to do it and he
even tries to rationalize his actions no
no I needed that because I'm gonna make
the world a better place I'm gonna make
a world of a way more interesting place
your your soul right Eternal damnation
for you that was a sacrifice I was
willing to make in order to make that
happen right the needs of the many
outweigh the needs of the few the
reality here is he's not really
apologetic for it and so in spewing all
this stuff about everything he's seen
suddenly you end up having Valeria that
transforms into a demon really and like
really Mephisto this could have been
impersonating her and then like really
tormenting Dr Doom and it's like I've
seen this life that you say you've seen
Dr Doom I see how you save everything
and so on and so forth you're never
going to attain it that's going to be
your damnation here right your eternal
torment is going to be that you know
without a shadow of a doubt that your
one dream in this world actually comes
true that you become this leader of this
Earth You Lead it into Utopia you become
everything that you believe yourself to
be and you're never going to be able to
attain it that's going to be your health
and so literally a fight breaks out
between the two and it's pretty knock
down drag out but in the middle of all
this mistress death appears and is like
done this fight's over right he will
return to his life Mephisto now here's
the thing even Mephisto himself
regardless of any level his level of
power he has is not stupid enough to
fight mistress death She's the literal
living embodiment of death all she has
to do is will it and Mephisto ceases to
exist that's it I mean that's literally
what you're talking about here so not
even he is stupid enough to invoke her
ire and the funny thing about this is
that where Dr Doom asks right like are
you doing this so that I can truly go
back to Earth and become the person that
saves it and her response is no it's
because you will become my greatest
servant of all you will bring a level of
death and destruction that the world has
never seen it's a crazy thing because
what ends up happening is that after
this whole circumstance arrives or it
really ends that Doctor Doom wakes up in
the home of Morgan lafaye who had taken
his body back to her apartment and of
course the two of them are joined by uh
by Blue Marvel now as soon as Doctor
Doom sees Adam Brashear he immediately
fires on him and gets him out of there
because Dr Doom knows how powerful Adam
Brashear is he knows how capable he is
and if a true knock down drag-out fight
between the two happens that given his
current circumstance it's highly
unlikely that Dr Doom will be able to
overpower Adam Brashear and basically
keep him from from being arrested right
so that's why he literally sends them
flying in the moment to sort of get him
out of the way at that point yet again
Kate the Conqueror pops up
getting the Conqueror appears and it's
one of those things where it's kind of
an information brokering right at that
point Dr Doom's like okay King I need
you to Rattle your brain I need you to
tell me what timelines there are where I
was successfully killed in this moment
Here and Now not five days ago right not
50 minutes ago if this moment right now
I need to know who it was that killed me
and the response of King is it was
Taskmaster and he was hired by Advanced
idea mechanics and so what literally
ends up happening here is Dr Doom finds
the base of advanced idea mechanics
right he literally breaks in he steals
their weapons and starts shooting the
place up he kills everyone right he does
he like every single soldier they have
they all die now here's the thing I had
previously stated that Dr Doom without
his powers is basically useless I was
wrong right I was 100 wrong unlike most
people on the internet I can admit when
I'm wrong when I'm when I think I'm
wrong unfortunately I usually never
think I'm wrong so I usually never admit
I am wrong just kidding but here's one
of the things right I never really
consider Dr Doom to be capable when he
didn't have his arms and Armament this
dude's a beast man this guy's rolling
through here with just the with just the
biggest gun I've ever seen killing
everyone he sees right just overpowering
them all he duplicates himself several
times over and all those different
forces right all those different
versions of himself start attacking all
these different soldiers so we still use
those powers to a degree but at the end
of the day it comes down to him and
Taskmaster now this is when you really
get to see what Doctor Doom is capable
of I never believed he was good when it
came to hand-to-hand combat mostly
because you never really see him doing
hand-to-hand combat it's always like you
know I'm Dr Doom and magical spells and
just badassery all over the place that's
usually all you ever see but seeing him
facing off against Taskmaster like this
and overcoming Tony Masters is
impressive as hell right it's a pretty
pretty cool thing because remember when
you're fighting against Taskmaster
you're not just fighting Tony Masters
you're fighting everyone Tony Masters
has ever fought right so you're fighting
Captain America Spider-Man Deadpool
Wolverine like all these different
characters because this is the Rolodex
he just pulls those fighting styles out
and depending on the circumstance
especially when he was fighting black
panther he actually merged all those
fighting styles into one to where he
would punch like Captain America but he
would Dodge like Spider-Man and he would
kick like Deadpool it was cool man it
was it was just one of the coolest
things just some amazing moments that
you see in Marvel Comics and so once Dr
Doom gets the upper hand on Taskmaster
knowing that taskmaster's mission was
quote unquote finished with Dr Doom the
next thing he wants to know is who are
you supposed to go after next right
because he literally asked him who hired
Advanced idea mechanics to kill me right
that's what I want to know who hired
them to take me out who hired you to
take me out and where he initially won't
give that explanation the reality here
is Doctor Doom's smart enough to know
that if Taskmaster is going after Doctor
Doom then Taskmaster is also going after
people associated with Dr Doom and so
that's when he's like I want to know who
this is who is it you're supposed to go
after next and that's when he says it's
for Xena right it's a woman named for
Xena and at that moment Doctor Doom
basically ends up realizing there's a
much bigger thing going on here and
immediately goes after that chick right
immediately goes after for Xena now the
other thing that takes place here is
kind of working his ranks up right
basically continuing to take out
Taskmaster as well as what seemingly the
rest of advanced idea mechanics he's met
by the arrival of Modoc now Modoc
doesn't really offer much of the way of
a challenge here for Dr Doom he kind of
does but he kind of doesn't he tries to
shoot him with like a mental blast Dr
Doom has the shield of Taskmaster and
his sword he just stabs Modoc in the
chest but this killing is also a long
time coming because remember Modoc was
part of Intelligentsia which was the
organization that stripped Doctor Doom
of his intelligence if you're not
familiar with that storyline we're
actually covering it right now in my
videos on Jonathan Hickman's Fantastic
Four so we'll post a link to that video
down in the playlist but in the midst of
all this you end up picking up on
Liberty Island now Liberty Island is a
place that has these kind of weather
stations that are being created or be
being used by this woman named frezina
and the idea behind this is it's
basically an attempt even if only in a
smaller localized space to basically
control weather in Marvel Comics that
kind of stuff happens all the time it's
not really a new thing it's not really
Landmark it's just something that
Christopher cantwell's throwing in here
to show what she's doing but in the
midst of all this one of the things that
we learned is she is from latviria and
we know this because there are
discussions that take place between her
and the people around her where they ask
questions like you know is Doctor Doom
really an effective leader you know is
it a good thing that he's gone that kind
of stuff and she's like understand right
the law of sedition and rendition those
individuals who speak ill of vladveria
and its leader especially Liberian
citizens will literally be tossed in
some kind of a re-education camp I don't
want to be one of those guys so I'm
going to go back to doing what I was
doing right that kind of a thing it's
just kind of bred into them in terms of
how they function the other part of this
here is that while you do have Doctor
Doom in a library who's basically
reading up on for Xena the reason why
this name is so significant comes when
he's visited by Kane the Conqueror yet
again and when when the the two of them
really start talking is Doctor Doom
saying in these visions that I had the
woman that I end up marrying is for Xena
like that's the person that I end up
marrying and that I end up having a life
with so the reality is if she's a target
of advanced idea mechanics and they're
looking to kill her by using Taskmaster
or somebody I've got to find a way to
keep her alive she's supposed to end up
becoming my wife and so this is a really
significant moment here and there's
actually history between Doctor Doom and
forsina indirectly and the reason why
this happens is because you do have a
little bit of a skirmish that takes
place between Dr Doom and Kane the
Conqueror but the significance of this
really comes in the form of the fact
that when Doctor Doom ends up visiting
for Xena she initially rebukes him right
I mean at first she's kind of like oh my
God it's Lord Doctor Doom you know that
kind of a thing but once the veil goes
away and he tells her just address me
like a regular person she doesn't like
him and in fact she hates him because he
tells her like I've had visions and you
and I are supposed to get married which
is one way to propose all right just
like run up on a random chick hey random
woman over there I've had Visions we're
supposed to get married uh you want to
get hitched right that's not gonna work
but the reason why frezina hates Doctor
Doom is because there was a point during
doomor when Dr Doom had invaded wakanda
and stole its vibranium that a
journalist in Liberia had spoken out
against Dr Doom because of that and what
Dr Dum had done is he had jailed that
guy basically for his first edition
right for speaking ill of vladviria end
of Dr Doom and that guy is still serving
a prison sentence that guy is the father
of farsina and that's why she hates Dr
Doom because the guy was just doing his
job and the price he paid is is
basically a life of imprisonment and
even Dr Doom goes as far as to say I
should have had your father executed for
what he did just be happy in the fact
that I didn't and I was feeling
particularly generous now that's the
most Doctor Doom thing to say to be
honest with you but in the midst of all
this a couple things happen the first is
that you basically have the arrival of
Adam Brashear alongside Herbie and then
you have the arrival of silver Sable and
Victorious now I've kind of held off on
talking about them up to this point
though way things had played out with
their characters is that Victorious was
kind of like the second in command to
Doctor Doom whenever he's not in Liberia
she's the one who runs the show and so
where you basically had the simcardians
who were attempting to invade Liberia
successfully did so and then took over
the country that Victorious was
basically ousted but the other part of
this is that silver Sable being as smart
as she is had realized something else is
going on here and she was actually being
used and so she and Victorious work
together to try to find Doctor Doom so
they could basically put all their
information together and figure out what
the bigger picture is now of course blue
Marvel being here is just for the
purpose of trying to you know to grab
Doctor Doom and it's really an amazing
moment because a fight breaks out
between the two and Adam Brashear holds
his own against Doctor Doom and thus one
of the things that I hope you notice
here in terms of Doctor Doom facing off
against uh against Blue Marvel it's
really him just trying to hold off the
power of Adam Brashear and this is due
to the fact that in this moment Doctor
Doom is not as powerful as Adam Brashear
it's a pretty cool moment right it's a
pretty cool and badass thing where
literally blue Marvel is more powerful
than Dr Doom In This Moment now of
course yet again Kay the Conqueror shows
up
I told you he would show up at like the
funniest moments and at the most
inopportune times what's really cool
though is that this is an exceedingly
opportune time he shows up here with
just this insane weapon and is like okay
Doctor Doom this is for you because
remember you gotta live so that you can
make the world easier to conquer for me
like I told you as his whole motivation
of showing up here strictly for that and
in fact what you end up having is Adam
Brashear who immediately attacks Kane
the Conqueror because Kane the Conqueror
destroys Herbie and so in that moment
Adam Brashear like the blue Marvel kills
Kane the Conqueror right he kills him on
the spot just incinerates that guy and
that's when doctor Doom's like okay yeah
we gotta get out of here like we gotta
find a way to bail the other part of
this though is that no one's prepared
for what comes next because what happens
here is that with Kane the Conqueror it
wasn't simply just a weapon that he gave
Doctor Doom what he also gave him was an
advanced suit of armor from his own
timeline right from King's own timeline
and doing that what it does is it
restores Victor Von Doom back to his
full power he's got the full brunt of
his technology combined with his
mysticism and advanced Weaponry from
Kane the Conqueror blue Marble's like
look here's the thing Doom we have to
put these grievances aside this black
hole is going to emerge everything's
going nuts with the antleon collider we
have to do something and the response of
Doctor Doom is no like I'm not going to
do that I'm going to go home and I'm
gonna take care of my country Reed
Richards wanted to be the one to run the
show that let Reed Richards run the show
and if the entirety of the project goes
awry and a black hole Singularity opens
at the Moon I will deal with it and I
will take care of it but I will take
care of it because I'm better than he is
but I want the world to know that Reed
Richards is a failure I want the world
to know that he's nowhere near as
capable as I am literally Dr Doom is
willing to potentially see the Earth
destroyed just to make Reed Richards
look bad and so where this picks up is
actually the first time they've spent
any meaningful time together over the
course of the story arc now Dr Doom and
Kang have a history a pretty the history
and in fact back in the day in the
original comic escapes me but back in
the day in Marvel there was a point when
came to conquer after he adopted the
identity of Rama Tut and was defeated by
The Fantastic Four in ancient Egypt he
ended up coming back to the modern era
and then after meeting Dr Doom basically
fashioned the suit of his own that was
similar to Dr Doom and started calling
himself the Scarlet Centurion right so
just one of those little bits of History
here but the long and short of it is
that these guys have a lot of respect
for each other but their egos are off
the charts right they're like they're
like Dwayne Johnson cooking the books
with Black Adam the hierarchy of power
in the DC Universe is about to change
right I mean like it's just a whole new
level of ego like that's literally what
this is and so that's why one of the
first things they talk about here is
whether or not they're actually related
and that's one of the things that's just
kind of a big question that's existed in
Marvel Comics for eons and eons and the
reason why is because Kane the
conqueror's real name is Nathaniel
Richards and of course you have Reed
Richards and Reed Richard's father's
name is Nathaniel Richards so for years
and years in Marvel Comics and I mean
when I say years I mean like decades
right for like the last 50 years or so
in Marvel Comics give or take a little
bit fans always found themselves asking
the question is Kane the Conqueror
Nathaniel Richards is he descended from
Doctor Doom as he descended from Reed
Richards and in fact they're going to
pose this question as to whether or not
Nathaniel Richards right came the
Conqueror is actually the father of Reed
from like maybe a different universe or
operating under a different change in
his character's history or whatever the
case happens to be we'll talk about that
here in a second because it gets a
little wonky but one of the things that
happens here is that these guys are
basically taking the long road right
instead of just like teleporting
somewhere or having some vessel from
Liberia pick them up and take them where
they need to be or came to conqueror
using technology instead they literally
have to lay low so they're going old
school man they're hitching rides and
like train cars and like walking and
stuff it's cool unfortunately for a
couple of these poor sets these guys
basically decide to stow away on one of
the trains literally hitch a ride and
then like one of them gets into the
train car with Dr Doom and Kang and is
like hey what's going on gentlemen do
you guys mind sharing this train car
with me now is anybody who knows
anything about Doctor Doom knows this
guy does not suffer vagrants
so they blast him out of the train car
and send that guy flying to his Doom
right after that it picks up with the
two of them just kind of there like a
campfire right and again that's kind of
how this conversation continues on that
what ends up happening is Dr Doom even
goes as far as to say I've heard rumors
that you're read Richard's father and
the response of of King is I've heard
that too but he looks nothing like me
now the reason why this is being thrown
out here is because this goes back to
Jonathan Hickman's Fantastic Four which
we need to continue because if anything
after the the after where we stopped
it's just a handful of like small
ancillary stories right just like one
shots and little mini series and this
Jonathan Hickman just kind of cleaning
things up so it's not Essential by any
standard of measurement but it would be
fun to go back right because we still
have Franklin Richards from the future
who's currently in the present day doing
his thing in Crazy levels of reality
warping and so on and so forth plus
there's the ultimate fate of Ben Grimm
which is kind of screwed up but the
thing about this is that when Jonathan
Hickman wrote The Fantastic Four and
specifically when we got what was called
the big hunt so all these different
variants of Nathaniel Richards Keith's
father across the Multiverse all facing
off against each other and jumping in
and out of different universes right Age
of Ultron Days of Future Past different
things like that that one of the big
theories that Rose to prominence during
that time is that because Reed Richard's
father's name is Nathaniel Richards you
had the great hunt you have variants of
Nathaniel that they all end up becoming
basically versions of Kang and so that's
what that theory came from initially or
really gained the most traction I should
say is that Kang is potentially the
father of wreath so again it's one of
these really interesting things because
when you're talking about a guy like
Kang who does time travel while he has a
lot has had a lot of identities over the
years the reality of this is that Kang
has actually forgotten a lot of the
things that he's done over the course of
his existence right a really good
example of this if you want to put this
to the test tell me what was on the wall
on the left hand side and your third
grade class what did your teacher have
written on the wall what was the name of
your third grade teacher and that's what
you're talking about here right came the
Conqueror jumps in and out of different
points in time all the time right and so
because of that it all just kind of
turns into an amorphous blob of things
he's done but that's why why you'll have
comics where somebody will say well King
what about the time that you did this
and he won't know what they're talking
about because he will have forgotten it
and so again it's just one of those
interesting things when it comes to his
character's history so that's why the
theory still holds traction and that's
why it's entirely true but of course
following this it's also Kang basically
telling Doom I'm not I'm not your father
and the response to Doom is I know
you're not perhaps I'm your father right
like it's one of the things where they
kind of go back and forth we never get
any definitive answers truth to tell I
don't think Marvel will ever give us a
definitive answer as to whether or not
Kang is related to Reed Richards or to
Dr Doom which one he's descended from
because it's just one of those cool
little Mysteries that just kind of
exists out there now of course following
this you have uh you have another poor
bastard that decides to roll up on Kane
the Conqueror and Doctor Doom as they're
walking down this uh deserted Highway
these two folks ride up on him right and
one of them's like so what do we got
here right I ain't never seen more
colorific looking chuckle ducks in all
my life what's your name fancy Cleopatra
referring to Kane the Conqueror and
they're like how about you Steely Dan
what's behind your iron curtain and of
course Dr Doom in response to this helps
them finish with all their living
anybody who is a
Doom
otherwise you will be made to meet your
maker and that's literally it but one of
the coolest things about this this is
one of the reasons why I love this comic
so much one of the coolest things about
this is that again there's a lot of
respect between the two depending on the
story arc they're mortal enemies but the
reality here is that the intelligence of
Doctor Doom can never be underestimated
by anybody even Reed Richards and people
like Valeria Richards the daughter of
Reed who's every bit as smart as Doctor
Doom and Reed himself people like Moon
girl who's that intelligent or even Adam
Brashear who's as intelligent right at
least that's what this story solidified
they all basically go to Doctor Doom in
some capacity as the guy that can answer
questions that they have that they
simply can't find answers to on their
own he's wildly intelligent and that's
one of the reasons that his character
even alongside Kang is so cool because
even Kang himself recognizes the
intelligence of Doctor Doom and the
reason why that needs to be respected
but Dr Doom also respects Kang because
between the two of them they have an
unwillingness to be defeated to defy all
the odds and to ensure they come out on
top more so than that what Dr Doom
respects Above All Is One a person's
intelligence and a person's fortitude
how hard are you willing to work to get
what you want do you take the easy Road
or do you take the Hard Road even if the
Hard Road doesn't need to be taken do
you take it anyway for no other reason
than the fact that it'll make you more
well-rounded and make you better and
Kane the Conqueror is very much the guy
who will take the hard road everything
he has he worked for with the exception
of the time travel device he stole that
I mean truth to tell let's be honest
with ourselves right it was literally
doctor Doom's time platform in the 30th
century and Kane just took it right but
outside of that outside of that
the guy the guy is unwilling to give
ground and will always do whatever it
takes to win and doom can always respect
that and so that's why you have this
this kind of conversation where Doom
asks the question why are you even
bothering to help me and the response of
of King is I explained I will conquer
the world that you save and the response
to Doom is I will save no world and
again King says no I've seen the Utopia
that you've created and then the
response to Doom is you've also seen
seen a future where Earth is overrun by
a cohort of mechanized dinosaurs and
that's when Kang makes this amazing
point and he says true still wherever Dr
Doom stands there exists a lust for
power one I can use to my advantage and
that's where Doom calls us Bluff and he
says honestly I think you're just lonely
and the two of them just kind of start
going back and forth I am not you're
lonely no you're lonely I'm not lonely
because I'm Dr Doom and I'm a
misanthrope well I'm more of a missing
I'm a misanthrope times two right it's
literally just kind of this bickering
back and forth and this sort of
nonsensical and almost sort of a
bromance that exists between these guys
I don't know if anybody uses that word
anymore but it's great to see doom and
Kang relating to each other in this way
because more often than not you see them
as enemies it's cool because literally
after they they share this laugh
together the response of Doom is I will
destroy you king and the response of
Kang is I'll destroy you first Victor
right so it's just one of those cool
little moments that goes on there now
having said that once they make their
way to Texas what ends up going on here
is Doctor Doom has what he calls an Ace
in the Hole in the sense that he was
able to kind of contact people through a
kind of underground Network and say like
I need something delivered to me at this
location so at this point they're
literally just biding time and waiting
when out of nowhere they're met by the
arrival of Paladin with a minigun who
literally just starts spraying the whole
place down literally this guy's just
standing there with a minigun unloading
everything honestly it looks like an M60
but he's just spraying everything down
only for them to find out the way in
which they were found was because of the
orb now here's a few things to explain
here is Paladin an important character
no Paladin sucks he's always sucked he's
never been a relevant guy there's never
been an instance in the history of
Marvel Comics when all these villains
are all teaming up to face off against
the heroes and they're losing and then
Paladin shows up and the day's saved
that's never happened right the guy's
about as irrelevant of a mercenary as
anybody possibly can be but more so than
that the orb this guy's just downright
goofy but it is still cool to see that
they have their history intact so here's
the thing when it comes to the orb this
guy was completely and totally
Irrelevant in Marvel Comics until a
story was written it was called original
sin and what this guy had done is he had
discovered the dead body of The Watcher
which had actually been killed by Nick
Fury but he had taken one of the
Watchers eyes and because everything The
Watcher has seen over the course of his
existence was stored inside of his eyes
the orb but basically broadcast all that
information to the world so everybody
learned everything about themselves that
they had previously never known a really
good example of this is during oh my God
Jon and Hickman's Avengers The New
Avengers when Captain America was
originally part of the Illuminati during
the incursions when like the Multiverse
was collapsing and the Illuminati were
talking about destroying alternate Earth
that when he disagreed his mind was
white by Doctor Strange at the direction
of Iron Man and then he was thrown out
of the Illuminati so he didn't know any
of that stuff but during original sin
all those memories were restored to him
and then he had lost his super soldier
serum and just became this crotchety old
son of a gun and was literally going
like like going after the Illuminati
like he took over shield and brought
like the full might of the US Military
and the intelligence community on to
like find the Illuminati it was amazing
man because for a Time Captain America
was kind of a warlord and it was pretty
boss like it was amazing it's one of the
best moments in the history of Marvel
Comics but again the orb still has one
of the Watchers eyes Now The Watcher
himself is back right but the orb still
has one of his eyes meaning the orb sees
all like it literally has like what you
could argue to be Cosmic awareness
although there's nothing to indicate
that it operates on a universal level
but literally like with the hunt for
Doom it's Doom's over there in Texas
right he knows right off the bat and so
what ends up happening is King
brandishes really one of his older
weapons which is called the ultra diode
but what it does is it basically just
saps people love their willpower so it
reduces you down to the most pathetic
version of yourself right so most people
on Twitter and Reddit and the result of
this is that these guys just kind of
cower into like a fetal position and
just sort of cry about how like the end
is an eye their lives don't serve any
useful purpose or anything like that but
the cool thing here is that once the
this plane right this contact lands and
Dr Doom is given his Ace in the Hole
that what we end up finding out is that
it's actually the ultimate nullifier now
here's the thing man and I'm kind of
amazed that Christopher Cantwell is just
sort of treating this as a thing right
like it's just sort of there the
ultimate nullifier is quite literally
the Ultimate Weapon in Marvel right I
mean I would argue this thing is Way
Beyond The Power of an Infinity Gauntlet
because the thing about the ultimate
nullifier is that the power that it
possesses it's relative to the person
who's using it initially it was created
by Galactus and then it was attained by
the Fantastic Four during the original
Galactus Trilogy literally Johnny Storm
and The Watcher go to galactus's ship
tattoo they steal it they bring it back
to Earth they give it to a read and the
Reed starts brandishing this thing and
galactus's face and then Galactus just
flees for his life that's a very
simplified version of what happens but
like this thing scares the hell out of
Galactus and the reason why is because
if you put the ultimate nullifier in the
hands of an idiot it may not necessarily
work you put this thing in the hand of
Reed Richards you could annihilate the
universe Doctor Doom you could Wipe Out
the whole universe the benefit of the
ultimate nullifier is that doesn't just
destroy whatever you aim it at it
basically makes it so it never existed
so a really good example of this is that
if Doctor Doom were to point the
ultimate nullifier at Spider-Man then
Spider-Man would simply cease to exist
not only that it would be as if he never
existed so seemingly nobody would have
ever heard of Spider-Man nobody would
have ever liked any images of Spider-Man
that exists would ultimately be gone
right they would just disappear like
this guy the entire evidence of this
guy's existence would vanish forever
that's really the major implication of
the ultimate nullifier and there's
really no way to bring them back so
that's why I say I mean presumably you
could point this thing at like The
Infinity Gauntlet or any Cosmic entities
probably even the Living Tribunal maybe
I'm not really sure I guess it just kind
of depends but the thing is insanely
powerful so the fact that it's in the
possession of Doctor Doom means this guy
means businessman and so what ends up
happening is that once he has the
ultimate nullifier we end up finding out
this is the reason why King was here in
the first place now the reality here is
that Kang wanted to attain the nullifier
for himself off but unless you decided
to screw up the time stream Doctor Doom
had to get his hands on it in order for
Kang to take it from Doctor Doom things
have to happen in a certain order when
it comes to the progression of time
throughout the Universe and so as soon
as Dr Doom gets the ultimate nullifier
king turns on him and then steals the
ultimate nullifier but before he can get
away this is the crazy thing before he
can get away Doctor Doom quite literally
stabs Kane the Conqueror in the neck
like literally stabs him in the neck
right blood goes everywhere leaves him
for dead and then just takes off on his
horse right just like rides off on his
horse and so following that Dr Doom
basically ends up getting to Mexico and
when he arrives there which is kind of
weird to see he ends up basically
grabbing a payphone and he calls Reed
Richards from a payphone and the reason
why is because during the time when doom
and Kang were traveling together the
question that they had is how do we do
how do we end that black hole and they
were asking questions like can we use
antimatter it's like well antimatter is
still composed of mass so literally Mass
plus Mass equals more mass so if you
fire some kind of antimatter cannon at a
black hole all it's going to do is just
absorb all that mass and grow bigger
you're not going to do anything but feed
it and so that's where Doom's mind began
to sort of look over the entirety of the
situation that's when he calls up Reed
Richards and he says your black hole
solution is simple read my guess is that
it's standing right next to you and he
says Brashear the blue Marvel send him
inside the antleon experiment now the
initial response of Reed is in
antimatter Collision will just create
more mass and the response to Dr Doom is
listen you idiot right he says send him
past the Event Horizon he can generate a
massive amount of negative energy to
dissipate the black hole I know he
survived the nuclear explosion so
there's a chance The Singularity will
not incinerate him and then he
ultimately leaves now here's the reason
why that would work remember Adam
Brashear is an antimatter reactor right
he literally he's basically a guy that
draws all of his power from the
antimatter universe so imagine you're
not like Superman draws his power from
the sun right solar energy gives him all
of his abilities like it feeds his
abilities that's what happens with Adam
Adam Brashear instead of him being fed
by the power of the sun he's fed by a
whole different universe but it's also
why his power is seemingly Limitless
because so long as the Negative Zone
exists he'll be powerful and he can
presumably Channel all the power of the
Negative Zone in different forms and
Fashions it's why when it comes down to
like physical strength Adam Brashear is
arguably the single strongest character
in the Marvel Universe the best way to
test that and I hope Marvel gives it to
us one day I want to see blue Marvel
versus like World breaker Hulk I want to
see that fight because that would be
dope but literally because he's an
antimatter reactor that's the response
of Doctor Doom I'm not a physicist so I
don't really even know how all this
works but as I understand it it would
basically be two objects hitting and
just canceling each other out right
negative one plus positive one equals
zero that's really what this would be so
I'm kind of curious to see exactly how
this would play out well the way this
picks up is it picks up with Adam
Brashear the blue Marvel basically
traveling into the black hole for the
purpose of using his power to try to
cancel out the black hole and then
literally dissipate it is basically what
would happen for Dr Doom he's returning
to latviria now so what we're going to
do here is is with the Adam Brashear
portion it's not overly necessary at
this point in time but the hole just
behind this is that as he travels into
the black hole that the mission again is
for him to basically expound as much of
his energy as he possibly can literally
Channel it outward inside the Event
Horizon of the black hole or really
inside the singularity and then
basically collapse the black hole and
then make it out before he's ultimately
destroyed now obviously this is a Marvel
comic it's defying all laws of physics
as we know them
because nothing escapes a black hole
that's the significance of a black hole
so as as Adam Brashear gets into this
there's a few things that happen one
he's met by an alternate reality version
of Otto Octavius and that's when we end
up finding out these different visions
that uh that Dr Doom has been having
over the course of this story where he
has like a different life he basically
leads the world into a kind of
scientific Age of Enlightenment really
where he has like a wife and children
and so on that's what's on the other
side of this black hole it's a wormhole
is really what it is right it's a tunnel
that leads from the main Marvel Universe
to this alternate reality and that
what's been happening is Doctor Doom has
been receiving Visions from this
alternate reality of what his life in
that Universe looks like but the other
part of this and for reasons that I'll
never fully understand Christopher
Cantwell invokes The Brood right so like
this crazy looking alien race like
attacks and of course Adam Brashear
basically fights them off but it also
leads to uh Doctor Octopus being killed
in the process right this also reality
Auto Octavius being killed but before we
find out what really happens there what
we end up doing is jumping back to
Victor Von do right now with his arrival
in latviria you do have what are
basically is kind of inner Council right
so you got Boris you got Petra Lara and
a few other people but you also have
Christoph Bernard now the reason why
these guys matter is because one
Christopher nard is the heir to the
throne so as soon as this coup d'etat
happened Kristoff Bernard was like
Public Enemy Number Two Dr Doom of
course being Public Enemy Number One
because he was still alive out there
somewhere but Christopher nard is like
the adopted child of Doctor Doom and in
fact he's gone so far over the course of
his publication history to take his own
mind and use Christoph Bernard as a
backup for it so as we saw in Jonathan
Hickman's Fantastic Four for example if
something happened to Doctor Doom and he
lost his level of intelligence he could
download his mind from Christoph Bernard
and it would be like restoring your PC
right that's literally what it is here
and so Christopher nard is so important
because he's the rightful heir to
Liberia now you've also also got Zora
also known as victorious she was at one
point a kind of Herald to a degree of
Galactus when he showed up on Earth but
has largely been like the number two in
terms of doctor Doom's control of the
military and so on one of his most
trusted confidants but that's really
what's Happening Here is because when
they're out there just kind of surviving
and whatnot and Doctor Doom shows up on
the scene it's Doctor Doom riding a bear
which is probably one of the most baller
things that I think I've ever seen
doctor do I mean he just looks menacing
right like literally he's like riding a
bear and he's like I have returned and
like you see that and you're like yep
he's returned and we're not going to
argue with that are we guys and it's
like nope we're not gonna argue with
that at all because the Dude is riding a
bear and none of us wants to die not
only that his bear is his pet he named
him right like literally his name is
Novak
and it's not even his pet he's like this
is my comrade Novak see that he's fed
right so like it's one of those cool
things because for all the the the pop
and Circumstance and all the arrogance
that Dr Doom puts out there to the world
the reality here is he's Goofy on the
inside right he's he's gooey soft right
gentle he's he's he's he's he's got a
little a little bit of uh what a
sensitivity on the inside there right so
it's you wouldn't know it right but it's
one of those those funny things so as
soon as he arrives here what he says and
literally addressing his inner counsel
is he's like this coup d'etat originated
from inside uh latviria as far as I'm
aware and of course it started in some
Korea but the reality here is that I
ruled this country with trust I trusted
my people I trusted that they would not
overthrow me now he does trust to a
degree but he also recognizes they could
do that and in fact that was highlighted
in Hickman's uh of Avengers and New
Avengers when he was talking oh my God
when he was talking to Neymar's
Submariner in one of the best moments
ever so literally like when the
Multiverse is falling up heart and after
the name of the Submariner had made his
alliance with like Thanos and all those
guys only to find out the Thanos is
exactly what we thought he was which was
just a crazy guy that loves to kill
stuff he abandons the cabal he shows up
at Dr Doom's doorstep and it's like
you've got to help me and Dr Doom is
like uh okay so here's the thing Namor
I'm a king you were a king Once Upon a
Time you understand the bigger picture
here right like do you really think the
people in liveria wouldn't kill me if
they chose to of course they would he's
like but uh I feed them and I protect
them I keep them safe from whatever
threats are out there so before they
they pray to whatever God they believe
in when they go to sleep at night they
give thanks to me it's like one of the
greatest speeches ever right and then he
tells the name of the Submariner you're
on your own right you threw in your lot
with Reed Richards and then you went to
Thanos and now you show up on my
doorstep asking me for help no sir Dr
Doom is no one's second choice he
literally just rejects him just because
of the fact that he felt like he was a
second choice it was an amazing moment
in in Marvel Comics but the thing about
about this is that as he talks to them
he does know that at any point in time
his own citizenry could literally rise
up against him but it's the fact that
it's happened that now he questions
everybody so he tells them all you're
going to prove to me that I should trust
you and as each person goes in turn and
provides their own swearing of loyalty
to Dr Doom we meet up with a guy named
Vasily uh mccaff I think is how you
pronounce his name and it's one of these
things because as Dr Doom starts asking
him questions like you know how in the
world do you think this happened how do
you think this this whole coup took
place the response of Vasily as well as
obviously traitors in our midst right
subverting our security different things
like that and doom says allow me to read
you something and what ended up
happening here is that Doctor Doom reads
a letter that was written by Vasily to
basically a woman named Katarina who is
a Sim cardian and so that's when Dr Doom
and really Vasily starts to realize
Doctor Doom already knows vasily's one
of the traitors that he's one of the
people who worked against Dr Doom in
order to orchestrate orchestrate the
coup d'etat in latviria and so once this
comes to fruition Vasily can't really
lie like he can't really make anything
up right it's at this point if Dr Doom
asks him what do you know about this
letter assume it's rhetorical assume he
already knows the answer and so that's
when Vasily is just like okay right The
Jig Is up like there's nothing he could
do and Dr Doom tells him I'll give you a
two minute running start this guy hauls
ass out the door because he knows Doctor
Doom well enough to know he's not
messing around Doctor Doom walks out
there and at one minute 59 seconds the
clock strikes two minutes he fires the
shot and kills Vasily on the spot and
then he's like feed him to my bear and
like that's it that's how Dr Doom gets
things done guys right it's it's I love
how he's handled I love the way
Christopher Cantwell writes Doctor Doom
here it's absolutely phenomenal but the
other part of this is he actually ends
up meeting with Victorious now he knows
Victorious well enough to know there's
no way she'd be involved in a coup
d'etat against him right so for for you
know to a degree she kind of gets a pass
but what he does is he presents her with
the ultimate nullifier and says the
ultimate nullifier takes an
astronomically focused mind in order to
use it otherwise the user will destroy
themselves or accidentally cause any
manner of things to come to an end so
I'm giving it to you to hold on to for
safekeeping because my mind is not as
focused as it used to be but then
following that he travels directly to
his castle in latviria and it's one of
the coolest moments because when the
coup d'etat took place a guy named
Dimitri fortunov was basically put in
charge of ladveria as the new ruler of
the Kingdom he's more of a puppet than
anything else kind of the guy who's
there to make it look like he's running
the show when in reality he's just being
told what to do so basically any
American politician and the reality of
this is that when Doctor Doom shows up
he's just kind of like the ruler of
Liberia an impressive title Dimitri
right an impressive title you must carry
it with dignity stand up straight after
all your king and hold your head high he
who Reigns looks down on those who don't
but something's missing yes a true
leader must have this and that's when Dr
Doom removes his helmet and shows his
face and says if you are going to be the
leader of Liberia this is what you must
look like and he forces this guy to
start cutting his own face up right to
disfigure his own face and then he
turned he says the ruler of latviria
must also be a god Dimitri ride can you
fly as a god flies and then he throws
him over the banisters and the guy falls
to his death and he's like alas a mere
mortal quite the pity but then in that
moment he actually ends up getting a
vision of his kids from the alternate
reality but they've cut their faces up
to look like him and the view of it is
so astronomically crushing to him that
he actually sort of collapses on the
spot right he almost passes out from the
strain because remember these visions
that he has of his kids of the life that
he could have is what he aspires to it's
what he wants it's almost like this life
is unsullied by everything that exists
out there in the world right now and so
what he does is he kind of gives us this
little bit of a monologue where he says
that over time you know once he was met
by Victorious and I wouldn't say nursed
back to health but Victorious was able
to help him regain his bearings Dr Doom
basically sits like he literally takes
his throne back and with him having the
ultimate nullifier one of the things to
understand is the world is scared out of
its wits now under any normal
Circumstance the world would look at
Doctor Doom retaking labyria with a bit
of a questionable lie and just kind of
be like can't we really trust this guy
but the dude's got the ultimate
nullifier in his possession and Dr Doom
as far as the world is concerned albeit
the world doesn't know the current
goings-on of his mental state but doctor
but the world sees Dr dooman believes
this guy having the ultimate nullifier
is enough to literally Wipe Out the
entirety of the universe like that in
the blink of an eye and so no one really
questions what it is that he wants and
in fact he goes as far as to say like
now that I've taken my Throne back I
don't want to conquer the world I don't
want to take over the world I have no
Grand aspirations for anything like that
but what I am going to do is I'm going
to put down this Rebellion that had
taken place in Liberia I'm going to
Route out everybody who was from
sincaria that caused this coup d'etat in
the first place and then I'm going to
take some karya and that's going to be
it and the world doesn't stand in his
way so literally this guy launches an
attack against the neighboring country
and let me tell you something man this
guy sun sun sun they they were not
prepared this guy comes in and it's just
like it's it's hell it's fire in
Brimstone right it's Old Testament man
this guy comes in and he's literally
like I seized control of this entire
country I conquered everything right he
says like the Sim cardian invasion was
over quickly my blood became charged
with the Verve as we stamped out every
conspiratorial smudge of scum every
Whisper of usurping vermin I even dusted
off my old Blaster buggy which is an
actual thing that he used to have back
in the day I haven't driven in ages what
fun it was to lay waste to so much at
such invigorating speeds here was Doom
at his greatest I I am a strong
proponent of Total War and no quarter if
you're going to break the back of an
entire nation you might as well do it
right we even killed most of the
livestock they just cleaned slated
sankaria and it was as much of a message
as it was anything else this guy goes
full on Kaiser Soze right I don't know
if we ever ran over that right but like
Kaiser so it's like the story of Kaiser
sose is amazing we're going to kind of
scroll cover panels so you guys to see
what's going on but the story of Kaiser
sose is amazing because for those of you
guys who never heard about this it was
from The Usual Suspects right and it's
literally Kevin Spacey who gives the
story and he says that Kaiser sose was
just like this drug Runner right this
guy that ran like a small little drug
operation and that was it but you had
these these Hungarian Warlords that
wanted to basically make a name for
themselves and what they knew is that
true power is not how much you have and
how much you control it's about your
willingness to do what the other guy
wants so these Hungarian Warlords I
think they were Hungarian basically show
up at uh Kaiser sose's home they find
his wife and kids right they basically
do what they will with his family and
when Kaiser sose gets back he finds his
wife has been violated and his kids are
crying and so these guys literally tell
him we want your whole operation we want
it all we want the drugs the money we
want your contacts the whole nine yards
right they wanted to show Kaiser so say
that they were that they were men of
will that they were willing to do
whatever it took and so Kaiser so say
show these men of will just what will
really was this guy killed his wife and
his kids and then he executed every
single one of the Hungarian Warlords
except for one and then he let that guy
go and tell the tale and then once all
these guys like once once his family was
buried then he goes to work right he
killed these Hungarian Warlords parents
he killed their parents friends he
burned down the homes that they lived in
he burned down the businesses they
worked out of he killed the people who
owed them money and then he vanished and
that was it right you never found out
what happened to Kaiser Associates that
well you do but you got to watch The
Usual Suspects to find out that's
literally what this is man that's really
what this is it's like that guy said to
John Lithgow and that movie Ricochet you
didn't beat him you just pissed him off
and now you're cause now he's gonna
be out for blood and so what we end up
doing here is we basically switch over
to Doctor Doom basically finding
Katarina right after the letter that he
read to Vasily he ends up taking one of
the swords him and Katarina getting a
sword fight he cuts her down and that's
the end of it following that Katarina
tells him I'm not the one who started
the coup d'etat in latviria from
sincaria I'm not the one who caused it
instead she points him to the to the
person who did and what he ends up
revealing is that it's a woman he's
never met he doesn't know who she is
doesn't know what she's about but
ultimately these people launched the
Rebellion against Dr Doom from some from
some Korea to seize control of latviria
and that this woman herself had a
daughter and the daughter that she had
was basically Left Behind when this
woman fled after her husband was killed
This Woman's been in some Korea ever
since and been plotting to overthrow
Doctor Doom but her daughter was taken
by the rebel forces that sided with Dr
doom and then raised as their own the
girl is Victorious that literally the
number one really the number two
commander of doctor Doom's Army actually
has some Korean blood now Victorious
wasn't working against doctor do and in
fact she didn't even know her own
Heritage she didn't know that this woman
who had orchestrated this whole coup in
Liberia was her own mom she had no idea
that was the case and so instead what
Doctor Doom does really with with uh
Zora herself is he orders her to kill
this woman after telling Victorious that
this woman is her mom and while
Victorious does follow the orders as
they were given to her at the end of the
day Doctor Doom assumed that Victorious
wouldn't really care that she would just
see this woman as some Korean scum as a
rebel right a person who tried to
orchestrate a Revolt instead while it
doesn't necessarily lead Victorious to
Turning against Dr Doom entirely it does
permanently fracture the relationship
between the two of them she doesn't
trust him as much anymore and she
doesn't look at him the same way anymore
following that every single person who
was in some capacity as you know
associated with the coup d'etat in
latviria from sincaria whether they're
in Liberia as as collaborators and
orchestrators or whether they're from
some Korea or not it doesn't matter
they're all summarily executed by firing
squad so literally like Dr Doom takes no
prisoners and the funny thing about this
is this kind of Final Act is what he
does is he Muses to himself and he says
despite all this violence and all these
things that he's done at the end of the
day he has no intention of staying this
way that what he's going to do is he's
going to travel to the Moon he's going
to find a solution to fix this whole
antleon collider problem and then he's
going to become the version of himself
that he saw in his Visions the version
of himself that by all standards of
measurement is much better and far more
peaceful than he is right now and has
led the world into a place where it
becomes more more advanced right
basically ushering ushering in a new era
but notice this Dr Doom's not doing it
because it's the right thing to do none
of it comes from an altruistic motive
he's doing it because he sees it as his
best possible chance to rule the world
and so following this once he completes
all of his research and everything and
literally develops a plan then what he
says is he's kind of devised a whole
like laser and experiment and so on
which is way beyond my ability to
comprehend but basically it keeps
getting fired into the black hole which
will help to reduce the black hole in
size the problem with this is that
doctor Doom's ego becomes his own
problem that what happens here is that
as he talks to Reed Richards who
literally just wants to wish him good
luck Dr Doom's own ego and really his
own self-consciousness starts to become
an issue when he starts to believe that
Reed has an ulterior motive that reads
just like yeah good luck Doctor Doom
you're gonna need it man because maybe
Reed Richards has realized something
about doctor Doom's experiment that Dr
Doom didn't realize himself but because
of how much he hates Reed and because of
all the insecurities that he has in this
comparison to read that he actually
starts recalculating all of his
experiments he basically starts to
second guess himself and when that
happens he makes a fatal error because
when he does the machine fires off it
hits the moon and it blows part of the
Moon in half and then following that Dr
Doom disappears and so when that happens
he basically wakes up in this alternate
reality in this alternate universe where
he's met by his alternate self and this
is where things get really really cool
because as he meets his alternate
reality version of himself he doesn't
really attack him but instead he's just
like I want to learn I want to know how
it was you successfully managed to
conquer the world now notice the
conversation between these two is
starkly different because this good
version of Doom right this we'll call
him Victor right Victor does not use
phrases like here's how I conquer the
world here's how I subjugated Humanity
different things like that it's we and
us it's a collaborative effort from his
perspective whereas Doctor Doom is
seeing it as you did something that
allowed you to seize control of the
entire world and it's one of those cool
things because Adam Brashear survived
everything that had gone on and in fact
he ended up in this alternate reality as
well and what what really uh Adam
Brashear says is that the visions that
Dr Doom has been having of Victor's life
where he's got a wife and kids and the
world adores him and loves him that the
reality is it's a mirror that what
Victor's been receiving are the is
really the life of Dr Doom and so it's
one of those things where Victor looks
at Doctor Doom and his actions in the
main Marvel Universe and being a a kind
of warlord and all that kind of stuff as
a nightmare right he sees it as like the
worst possible version of himself that
he could potentially be whereas Doctor
Doom looks at Victor and sees Victor as
what could be the best version of
himself but again the motivations are
different Victor is afraid of the life
he would have as Doctor Doom because he
becomes the warlord Dr Doom loves the
life that Victor has because it allows
him to achieve his ultimate goal as a
warlord so again totally different
motivations totally different
perspectives but at the end of the day
they are in some capacity mirrors of
each other and that's what's so cool
here because as they begin to talk this
Victor personality kind of starts to rub
off on Doctor dude to a degree right
where Dr Doom is perceiving all of this
as Victor just because he's so much
smarter than everybody and like that's
it but one of the things Victor says is
you're wrong about that and I want to
hear you say that you're wrong I want to
hear you tell me that you were wrong and
the response of Doom is I was wrong
right and it's really hard for him to
say because he's got to swallow his
pride to do it but then they get to the
home of Victor which is a really nice
and beautiful home but it's not the
castle of doomstadt in Liberia and Dr
Doom asked Victor like why would you
give up our Birthright why would you
give up this Castle to live in this this
kind of this Hubble as he calls it right
like this this small home that just does
not really stand as a testament to the
greatness of who we are and the response
of Victor is because none of this is
about how great I am none of this is
about how awesome and intelligent I is
Victor Von Doom am that's not what this
is supposed to be this was all done for
the legitimate betterment of humanity to
make the world a better place for people
more so than that what he also says is
you are looking at this this and you're
really looking at the world from your
own limited perspective you look at it
in terms of what you can make the world
into being I look at the world from the
perspective of what can I and the rest
of humanity turn the world into what can
we make the world because it's one of
those things where he says the result is
that regardless of how you perceive
Humanity whether you're exceedingly
misanthropic and make this argument that
the human race is the worst thing to
happen to Earth or you're more
optimistic where you say the potential
of humanity far outweighs the terrible
things that we've done the reality is
that the human race is greater than the
sum of its parts as a singular entity
with a singular ideology and a motive
the human race cannot be stopped from
achieving anything but instead it's it's
literally barriers between countries and
its motivations from world leaders right
and different things like that it's the
limited perception of the World by
Humanity that makes Humanity so limited
and so when he's like once you start
breaking that down the possibilities are
endless and what he reveals is it's like
this isn't just Earth where this happens
the every single Race Across the
Universe we all collaborate now the
shiar the cree the scroll the badoon the
whole nine yards we share information We
Share technology that we protect those
civilizations as much as they protect us
and while our technology was vastly more
limited than theirs because Humanity as
a whole had not achieved Interstellar
travel there was a level of power
regarding various superheroes that exist
on Earth that those other other
civilizations didn't have so we let them
have some stuff they let us have some
stuff and the universe is better off for
it and that's what's so fascinating here
because even Victor says like all these
Grand weapons that exist out there and
these Grand Powers the Infinity Stones
The Cosmic Cube the Crimson Gem of
sidorak you know the the casket of
ancient Winters the dark hole there's no
need for those things anymore there's no
need for these crazy you know artifacts
of power because nobody really views the
world in such a limited capacity in that
way anymore we don't need it we do
what's right because it's best for
Humanity and so as this whole
conversation station takes place that
what Victor tells Dr Doom is you can
achieve this you can do this on your own
home world you can literally bring this
world or really bring what I've done to
your own world but you're going to have
to drop this facade you're going to have
to drop this armor that you have you're
gonna have to learn to forgive guys like
Richards and you're gonna have to heal
your face and he says the reason why you
have to heal your face is because you
know just as well as I do at any point
in time you could heal your face you
could restore your face back to a sense
of normalcy but you choose not to
because having a scarred face allows you
to remember how Humanity has wronged you
that instead of becoming one with
humanity and leading Humanity you want
to subjugate the human race because you
see yourself as better than them you are
the very definition of a misanthropic
narcissist right like you believe people
don't matter and they should be
subjected or subjugated because you're
somehow more capable than they are and
he says think about it for a moment
Victor it's all a farce A desperate it
and honestly pathetic attempt to conceal
your endless fear it currently permeates
every fiber of your existence all the
way down to the silly finger guns in
your metal Gauntlet hand it's all
ludicrous your entire mode of being is
ludicrous you know that I'm right and
when he says that it's the final straw
Doctor Doom kills Victor on the spot
then he sees his control of the ultimate
nullifier in this alternate reality and
wipes out the whole universe literally
kills the whole universe on the spot he
ends up having you know taking Adam
Brashear out and Adam Brashear arrives
back on Earth but Dr Doom is just like
no I will not have it said that I Dr
Doom Victor Von Doom the smartest being
in existence has somehow joined the
limited intellectual minds of humanity
and I've somehow become a part of them I
don't want to be infected by the human
race I don't want to be that kind of a
person if the human race will become
better it's because I will make them
better I will lead them into becoming
better because I will subjugate them and
turn them into something better but if
Humanity could be better it would have
already been better by now Humanity
doesn't want to be better because people
are stupid but I will make them better
and so it's it's like the most
misanthropic thing ever right but
literally wipes out a whole universe on
a spot kills that entire universe and
then just goes back to his castle and
it's just like nope I'm him like I'm I'm
Doctor Doom there's not one ounce of
good in me and there never ever will be
and that's when Kang reappears to Victor
Von Doom and it's just like so I see
that you're back on your throne and the
response of Victor is yes I will not
become that guy he is a weak muelling
pathetic version of me and that's never
gonna be what's gonna happen to Doctor
Doom if I conquer this world it'll be
with an Iron Fist and all all Kane the
Conqueror does is just look on and
basically smile because at the end of
the day I don't know if it was the
manipulation of Kane that led to this
but seemingly King always knew how this
was going to turn out it was somebody
just up to Doctor Doom to figure it out
on his own but with that being said guys
we're gonna bring this video to an end
Amazing Story I loved it thank you all
for watching and I'll catch you all
later peace